Book called a billion wicked thoughts
that was written by a bunch of engineers
at Google and they were looking at
billions of search,
uh,
billions of google searches and you
know,
there's no shortage of pornography on
the Internet and it,
and there's much less by proportion than
there was when the Internet was first
invented.
And it's so interesting because it
actually turned out that one of the
things that drove the development of the
Internet and the technology was the
proclivity of young men to search out
sexually provocative images.
That was what was at the forefront of
the development of the nets.
Extraordinarily interesting.
They were motivated to,
they were motivated to use it for that
purpose.
And that provided the platform from
which it emerged.
Amazing.
Anyways,
the Google engineers looked at
pornographic search processes and then
segregated male searches from female
searches.
And what they found was that the mail
search out images probably surprise no
one,
no one considers that,
you know,
particularly interesting.
But the female searched out literary
representations of pornography.
It was written.
So I can give you an example of that.
If you know about harlequin romances,
does everybody still know about those?
Anybody not know about those?
Okay.
Well there are mass market romances and
have a very stereotypical type and
they're.
The original ones were pretty harmless
in terms of no violence and no real
sexual contact con content,
but that was 40 years ago and they've
differentiated tremendously and now
there's hardcore harlequin romances and
with,
with particularly garish covers.
And then there's the old,
you know,
more tame basic sexless and aggression
list romances where everything is
implied and not explicit,
but the explicit ones exist.
So they did a plot analysis of the
typical pornographic female fantasy.
Well,
and it was.
So,
it's so comical because engineers did
this and social scientists would never
do this because they'd be probably too
concerned about the ethics of it or some
damn thing.
But engineers,
you know,
they'll just plow ahead with no concern
whatsoever for such things and they
actually discover things that way.
And so they,
they discovered the basic plot of the
female pornographic literary product and
they identified.
So basically what happened was that a
innocent well meaning and attractive
young woman encounters a male who's a
bit of a monster and the monster.
There's five types of classic male
monster for all your males who want to
know this is what you can become a
vampire.
That's a good one.
We're wolf,
billionaire pirate and surgeon.
Okay.
So that's very interesting because.
Well first of all there's a dominance
thing.
There's a.
Now you're actually blushing.
You know,
you're actually blushing about that.
That's very,
very funny.
So sorry to point it out,
but it's so comical,
you know?
I know,
I know.
It's so funny.
I was reading this,
I was reading this.
It was just cracking me up.
I thought,
oh my God,
really?
Pirate Vampire,
all of that explains it.
What about all these damn vampire shows
right there?
So popular online.
There are so popular on Netflix.
Oh yes.
And then there's the war wolf.
There's nothing sexier than a werewolf
apparently,
but I mean,
so there's predatory dope.
There's predatory dominance that's
implicit in that,
right?
With a billionaire,
it's more abstract,
but clearly that's an indication of very
high success in the male dominance
hierarchy,
so,
but there's this desire for aggression
that's in that are real aggression,
right,
and it's not surprising to me,
to me at all,
it makes perfect sense,
but what?
But the basic plot is that the woman
encounters this mysterious and
aggressive male and teams.
That's the female hero myth as far as I
can tell,
it's beauty and the beast and so it's
because,
well,
there's no fun in taming someone who's
already tame and what makes you think
you really want someone who's taken many
ways.
There's no interest in that.
Plus when,
when,
when chaos manifests itself,
what makes you think that someone tame
is going to be good for anything and
it's a real question and so that
aggression is absolutely vital.
It's absolutely necessary,
but because it's in incredibly
dangerous,
which of course it is,
it has to be civilized.
And so what happens is that the
archetypal female in these pornographic
romances,
seduces and tames,
the aggressive male,
and that's her encounter with chaos.
Now it's more,
it's more complicated.
Of course,
females,
they're more complicated and that's
exactly how it is and it's no wonder
because there their lives are more
complicated,
but okay.